so what's Euler's theorem basically what
it is is when you're dealing with
polyhedron okay these are
three-dimensional shapes made out of
polygons you figured out this formula
that the number of faces plus the number
of vertices equals the number of edges
plus two so if you know two of these
three quantities you can find the
missing quantity and I'll show you some
examples but just to explain a little
further the faces are basically the
sides okay of this 3-dimensional
polyhedron okay and they're polygons so
they're like rectangles squares
triangles Pentagon's you know that type
of thing the vertices these are the
points okay these are the points where
the line segments come together okay
that make up the polygon they come
together at a point those are called
vertices and then the edges are where
the faces come together and they form a
line segments so I'll show you what I
mean in a couple of these examples so
this one over here you can see looks
kind of like a cube maybe it's a square
prism maybe it's a rectangular prism but
the main thing is let's look at the
number of faces so you can see there's a
rectangle on the right the left above
below front and back so you basically
have six faces
okay now let's count the vertices the
vertices are these points so it's one
two three four at the base five six
seven eight at the top so there's eight
vertices and then the number of edges 1
2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 so there's 4 at
the top 4 at the bottom and 4 on the
sides so that's 12 plus 2 more let's see
if it makes sense 14 equals 14 okay it
checks out now let's take a look at
another example this one is a pentagonal
pyramid the base is a pentagon you can
see it's made up of five triangles okay
and it comes to a point here at the top
so if we count the number of faces
there's the one at the bottom that's the
Pentagon five and then there's five
triangles all the way around so we know
that there's six faces okay now the
number of vertices those are easy to
count one two three four five and six
and let's just leave the number of edges
blank for a minute let's just do a plus
two so this is 12 equals e plus two if
we subtract two
you can see the number of edges should
be 10 let's see if we can verify that
there is 1 2 3 4 5 at the bottom because
it's a pentagon 5 sides and then you can
see there's 6 7 8 9 and 10 so that makes
sense there's 10 edges last example we
have a triangle triangular pyramid but
prism because you have two bases that
are parallel congruent a pyramid just
has one base it comes to a point prism
has two bases that are parallel
congruent and they're separated by the
height so here we can see that there's
two bases and there's three rectangles
and make up the side so that's the side
so that's five faces there's 1 2 3 4 5 6
vertices so 6 points ok and if we look
at the number of edges we have 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 3 at the top 3 at the bottom 3
on the side so three line segments times
3 ok so that's 9 plus 2 more so 11
equals 11
so you got it so if you had a more
complicated shape you know that maybe
had a lot more sides a lot more faces by
just solving for two of these quantities
you could solve for the missing third
quantity so I hope this helped you
understand euler's theorem a little bit
better go ahead and subscribe to the
channel check out some of my many other
past videos and I look forward to seeing
you in the future ones I'll talk to you
soon